Our calcium heart scans worth the radiation. I have high home assisted and low triglycerides and high Apple B.
So, high Apple B is another cardiac function that is concerning. The low triglycerides is a positive high home assisted is concerning.
Calcium heart scans will tell you any blockages that have calcified. So, that was a scan that came out about 20 years ago, I think.
So, I remember I got a letter from the local MRI place saying that they would do it. They gave me these letters out to doctors that they would do free scans.
We would hope that we would refer patients for those. I never did that. I can't remember if it's a CT or an MRI, I can't remember because I never referred people for that.
Can it be valuable? Well, sure, it can be valuable. So, you know, if you have concerns, I think that's that's certainly a whole lot less invasive than going in with the scope and seeing how what kind of block it you have. So, yeah, I mean, if that was recommended to you.
And again, if that's a CT scan, you're going to have radiation that goes along with that. If it's an MRI, you're going to have probably contrast die. But Apple B is a heart by products to fat.
So, you got your cholesterol. Okay, so your standard blood test for, you know, cardio blood test, the most basic is going to have cholesterol, high density, lipoproteins, low density lipoproteins, triglycerides. Well, that's pretty elementary.
So, when you get into deeper tests, you're going to break down those low density lipoproteins into Apple proteins, and then you're going to break them down into oxidized lipoproteins.
So, that's what you get into a more depth cardio study, you know, if you have a person, you typically would only do that as a person has, you know, super high elevated cholesterol or triglycerides, or they had a cardiac event or they have, you know, other issues that they want to dig deeper and make sure they're, you know, what's going on with those.
So, what's a CT scan? Is there a radiation with that, you know, but it can give you some peace of mind. Again, remember, nothing's perfect. So, even if that all came back fine, it still doesn't need everything's perfect.
And again, remember, is it heart blockage? That is, is it arterial blockage that's causing the decrease blood flow, or is it constriction of the arteries? Well, it's both.
So, I mean, I mean, you all probably personally know somebody that went in and got a full athero workup and they said, my gosh, you could drive a back truck through your arteries and two days later they have a massive heart attack and done.
Well, what's up with that? Because the physical blockage of the artery is only one piece of it. You can have constriction of the muscles. And that's usually due to, you know, H. Pilari or heavy metal toxicity or Lyme disease, that's causing damage to the ACE receptors and causing constriction of the,
the endothelial arterial system. And then that's just constrictly the arteries and block it. So, there's different reasons why a person would have, you know, cardiac event.
So, but yeah, it can still give you some peace of mind to that you're at a higher risk because of calcified, you know,
endothelial cells or calcification of the endothelial cells. So, there can be some concern about that.